bonjour nicolas dupont aignan bonjour
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté mon
invitation on va pouvoir commencer du
coup avec la première question je vous
laisse du coup
arrêter ces trous
et s'éteint et mogi de téléphone pour
commencer derrière cette màj il y à un
élément sortie d'un smartphone je vous
propose déjà qu'on le découvre et
ensuite qu'on puisse en parler
c'est en l'occurrence un tweet de marine
le pen en 2010 cette déclaration commune
de marine le pen et nicolas dupont
aignan en effet après le premier tour
vous aviez rejoint marine le pen elle
vous avait promis le poste de premier
ministre en cas de victoire au second
tour face à emmanuel macron qu'est ce
qui a changé depuis cette photo
or rien de particulier j'ai choisi au
second tour on me ressort toujours cette
photo quand valérie pécresse et xavier
bertrand et les autres ont choisi
emmanuel macron second tour ont leur
sort pas toujours la même mais vous
étiez le seul candidat le pen seule à
faire un choix que je pense cohérent et
courageux j'étais pas toujours d'accord
avec marine le pen j'avais des points de
différence et d'ailleurs je l'avais dit
j'avais d'ailleurs même dit au mois de
mai lors du meeting commun que je
resterai moi-même boulistes mais entre
maquereau et le pen j'ai fait comme tous
les français il y en a 10 millions +10
millions qu'ont choisi marine le pen
d'autres qui avaient choisi macron est
il surprenant d'ailleurs en france c'est
que ça paraisse curieux en fait on m'a
jamais pardonner nos métiers le seul
donc ça oui allez oui mais il passe
comme ça parce que on n'a jamais compris
que quand il ya un second tour il faut
choisir j'aurais dû me planquer rester
dans mon coin dire je sais pas je le
reconnais les faits mais je n'espère pas
parce que je pense que ça sera pas ça
et je pense qu'on aura un autre second
tour avec des gens différents voilà mais
est ce que eric joray pas pareil sans
doute parce que j'ai vu que ça n'ait pas
été compris toujours parce qu'on est
dans un pays curieux en fait où on n'a
pas le droit de penser ce qu'on pense il
ya une sorte de pensée unique terrible
la raison pour laquelle
je pense que cette question est
intéressante c'est pas tant sur la
question du ralliement second tour ces
avantages si pour comprendre votre
vision de la france c'est votre
positionnement politique qu'est ce qui
vous rapproche ou vous différencie selon
vous de marine le pen a brief d'abord
une élection la présidentielle c'est
quoi c'est une personnalité avec son
parcours sa démarche son caractère et un
projet un programme à la maison j'ai un
parcours très différents de marine open
je suis un élu local j'ai été maire
pendant 22 ans j'ai sauvé une vie de la
faillite donc je pense très
prétentieusement que j'ai une expérience
plus solide et une capacité de
rassemblement et sur le programme je
suis gaulliste je pense qu'il ya des
points communs sur l'indépendance de la
nation mais qui a des différends sur la
vision de la société j'ai beaucoup de
propositions sur la participation dans
l'entreprise sur eux la lutte contre les
inégalités entre les hommes et les
femmes sur
la politique étrangère même s'il ya des
points communs voilà je pense que en
fait vous pourriez posé la même question
et on appose jamais à valérie pécresse
par rapport à ma que non mais j'insiste
être cela pose un peu là oui mais on
appose jamais dans les médias c'est très
intéressant comme si on voulait
m'enfermer dans un domaine et à produire
l'occurrence l'idée c'est de comprendre
votre vision est au courant de ce
passionnant mais je vous réponds aussi à
ma façon
voilà il ya un premier tour on choisit
on préfère quelques heures et puis un
second tour on élimine
j'avais raison d'éliminer macron parce
que c'est un dangereux personnage -
enchaînait que la question suivante la
roue est à nouveau lancé vous laisse
l'arrêter
c'est un des mots j vidéo on va pas
regarder un film ensemble concrètement
une vidéo va apparaître à l'écran je
vous propose qu'on le regarde on en
parle juste après j'ai 500 près de 600
mille abonnés général de gaulle avait la
radio de londres moi j'ai facebook c'est
donc c'était très court comme vidéo
c'était un court extrait de l'épisode 3
de la série documentaire la bataille de
l'elysée qui a été diffusé le 7 février
sur tf1 vous êtes effectivement très
actif sur les réseaux sociaux pour faire
campagne vous êtes d'ailleurs le
candidat à la présidentielle qui génère
le plus de réactions à vos publications
donc des like des commentaires
extérieurs selon les données de crowd
singles qui ont été compilés notamment
par france inter vos publications sur
facebook puisque c'est là vous êtes très
présents ont suscité près de 12,3
millions d'interactions sur la période
entre janvier et novembre 2000 21 c'est
près de deux fois plus que mails macron
près de deux fois plus que marine le pen
aussi d'abord première question comment
est-ce que vous expliquer un tel succès
parce que je suis moi même parce qu'en
fait je pense que les réseaux sociaux et
facebook notamment ça ne peut marcher
que si vous êtes sincère parce que les
gens n'adhèrent que s'il voit quelqu'un
qui dit ce qu'il pense et la grande
différence avec les autres vous ne
portiez sow marine le pen tout à l'heure
mais ça pour être sûr pécresse ou
d'autres c'est que je ne fais pas de la
politique depuis 20 ans par calcul
j'ai toujours pris mes décisions
fonctions ce que je croyais être
l'intérêt mon pays quand j'ai rompu avec
les républicains mp à l'époque parce que
il avait trahi il vote de 2005 si
j'avais suivi mon intérêt fallait
surtout pas je le fasse j'aurais peut
être ministre de sarkozy etc je peux
trouver insupportable contre à istres
vote des français donc moi je suis
sincère dans mon combat politique et
c'est pour ça qu'il ya quelques
personnes qui m'aiment bien et c'est
pour ça que ça dénote et je pense que
j'exprime sur facebook que les médias
français ne me permettent pas d'exprimer
c'est à dire pas parce que je suis
complètement écartée des médias les
scores sont ahurissants je crois que
j'ai 0 5% de temps d'antenne sur france
inter mais
électorale elles sont pas respectées en
période électorale il a bien suivi qui
ne sont pas respectées mais est ce qui
se fait en deux temps aujourd'hui avec
un temps savez d'équité c'est puis
dégâts l'équité c'est le bon prétexte
pour éliminer ceux qui plaisent pas ou
la règle n'est pas la bonne selon vous
mais ne la reconnaît pas appliquée j'ai
0 5% de temps d'antenne sur france inter
monsieur roussel dont le candidat aux
européennes a fait beaucoup moins que
moi à dix fois plus de temps d'antenne
que moi donc je veux dire que j'ai les
réseaux sociaux je reviens sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est très important
pour quoi surprendre parce que ça permet
de parler librement sur france 2 c'est
près de 5 % du temps d'antenne ah non
vous avez sur le dernier mois pas du
tout oui mais ça c'est le dernier mois
parce qu'ils ont il ya eu zéro pendant
un truc 11 mois je n'ai jamais un
journal télévisé sur france 2 je n'ai
jamais une grande émission donc non il
ya une telle inégalité de traitement
entre ceux qui sont choisis adoubé par
le système et ceux qui sont recalés par
le système que heureusement que j'ai les
réseaux sociaux et s'il ya autant de
gens sur les réseaux sociaux bah ça
prouve que ce que je dit peu intéressés
et pour bien comprendre là dessus sur la
question du traitement par les médias
donc la question du temps de parole pas
rentrer dans les délais mais c'était
très clair en parler long de sommeil
leur démocratie il ya aussi la question
du traitement
qui avait comparé les journées c'est ce
que c est ce que c'est ça qui pose
problème selon plus que sur le nom si
vous voulez moi je crois que les
français sont intelligents quand ils
voient un journaliste qui
qui cirent les pompes du système il le
voit très bien ils sont pas cons ça ça
me gêne pas le journal ils sont libres
du ski vol ce qui me révolte c'est
l'inégalité temps de parole à un point à
uris ans on va passer à la question
suivante je relance la roue et je vous
laisse pas arrêter quand vous le
souhaitez
à la pendule c'est un chrono c'est un
chronomètre c'est un mois ça pourrait
être une pendule le sait mais en
l'occurrence et un chronomètre mais
derrière cette màj chronomètre j'ai en
fait vous poser une série de questions
l'idée étant de répondre par oui ou par
non un maximum de ces conditions on va
commencer sans plus tarder que la
première question est ce que vous êtes
prêts
faut-il rétablir un impôt sur les très
grandes fortunes oui faut-il sortir de
l'union européenne
ni oui ni non il faut changer l'union
européenne les enfants doivent-ils être
vaccinés contre le coc u19 non faut-il
diminuer le nombre de parlementaires oui
les musées doit-il être gratuit oui le
dimanche le dimanche faut-il abandonner
le nucléaire non faut-il rendre gratuit
le permis de conduire oui faut-il
utiliser l'écriture inclusive non
faut-il rétablir l'uniforme à l'école
non faut-il légaliser le cannabis nom
est utile d'aller sur mars
oui j'ai perdu du temps y aura-t-il une
parité femmes hommes dans votre
gouvernement oui faut-il interdire la
chasse le week end et pendant les
vacances blanche et mener le maquereau
est il le pire président la 5ème
république oui les violences policières
existe-t-elle oui malheureusement
comptez-vous abroger la loi sur le
mariage pour tous non faut-il rétablir
le service militaire oui
l'euthanasie doit elle rester interdites
oui etes-vous vegan non portez-vous que
du made in france malheureusement non
faut-il abroger la loi sur la pma pour
toutes non
on avait un petit peu dépassé le
chronomètre mais on ne va se permettre
de mal répondu ouais pas mal répondu et
ça permet de voir certains des éléments
de votre programme au delà des eaux là
des autres les autres sujets qu'on va
aborder pardon on va passer à la
question suivante on va relancer du coup
la roue et je vous laisse encore
était ça s'arrête sur un journal on va
donc découvrir ensemble un article de
presse une unes aux autres on va la voir
tout de suite je vous laisse le lire
le fessier charge nicolas dupont aignan
séquence 2010 petit-fils de gaulle le
petit-fils de gaulle charge nicolas
dupont aignan et marine le pen sa date
de 2017 vous faites très souvent
référence en l'occurrence au général de
gaulle grande figure évidemment
historique de l'histoire de france
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale puis
président français fondateur de la
cinquième ligne dans laquelle on est
aujourd'hui
comment est ce que vous aviez pris déjà
cette réaction du petit fils de coûter
jardin walsum m'indiffère complètement
puisque le génie n'est jamais ri dit r
il de gaulle n'est pas un gène est pour
vous non mais c'est sur cette personne
je ne suis pas pour la monarchie je ne
crois pas que je ne crois pas aux
héritiers dont on voit il dit ce qu'il
veut parler vous mais c'est pas parce
qu'il est pro prêt parce qu'il s'appelle
tout gaulle qui sait ce que c'est que le
gaullisme mais j'aime pas de leçons à de
gaullisme à recevoir mois entre macron
et l'indépendance nationale je choisirai
toujours l'indépendance nationale
maintenant parlons de l'avenir le
gaullisme c'est quoi c'est
l'indépendance de la nation c'est à dire
la démocratie c'est au peuple français
décidée pour lui-même et puis le
deuxième point c'est très important
c'est le rassemblement des français
autour d'un humanisme et c'est un point
qui m'est cher aussi donc c'est les deux
et je fais ce que je peux pour le
défendre quand j'allais beaucoup de oui
parce que c'est insensé dans
l'inspiration c'est une inspiration il
s'agit pas de regarder dans le passé il
s'agit de tirer des leçons voilà de
certains événements en tout cas il a
laissé la france en meilleur état qu
emmanuel macron et pourquoi se rattacher
à une figure historique quand on est une
personnalité politique c'est intéressant
d'ailleurs de voir que le général de
gaulle lui-même vers vous vous le savez
sûrement disait que le gaullisme sans de
gaulle je ne le soit pas mais bien sûr
bas se rattachait j'ai jamais dit et
j'ai toujours été très prudents et j'ai
toujours dis moi j'interprète je crois
que dans l'histoire de france récente
c'était il ya des leçons à tirer s'agit
pas pour autant d'imiter tout ce qu'il a
fait c'est évident c'est une sensation
une source d'inspiration comme bien
d'autres il ya une grande politique
clemenceau
et d'autriche eu lieu et c'est donc un
pays un homme politique et on le voit
bien parce que avec les guignols qu on a
donc une connaissance historique un pays
c'est un fil d'histoires c'est une
longue chaîne et on prépare bien
l'avenir si on a un peu des racines si
on sait d'où on vient si si on a des
repères la france n'est pas un pays
comme un autre il ya une exception
française ces valeurs liberté l'égalité
la fraternité c'est quelque chose de
différent donc si on connaît pas notre
histoire on est comme des bouchons
balader voilà ce qui explique d'ailleurs
la désaffection des français parce que
les français vous savez il aime
l'histoire mais c'est intéressant de
voir où en l'occurrence ça fait des
années que vous
on revendique une sorte d'héritage du
général de gaulle en tout cas que c'est
une source d'inspiration avancions que
je suis surpris de voir nos hommes
politiques qui ont gouverné
bazarder
détruire un héritage du conseil national
de la résistance qui était justement
l'alliage de l'indépendance nationale et
de conquêtes sociales et pour moi il n'y
a pas de conquête sociale possible si on
ne protège pas un pays est ce qui
explique le déclassement français
c'est-à-dire la pauvreté des français
parce que derrière ces des français qui
souffrent qui vivent avec des salaires
de misère c'est parce qu'on n'a pas
défendu les français et c'est ça
j'essaye de faire comprendre voilà c'est
tout c'est intéressant du coup de devoir
sets épiques mans à une figure que vous
que vous revendiquez souvent quand il
expliquait d'ailleurs que charles de
gaulle est souvent citée par quasiment
tous les candidats ce que les français
ont un souvenir extraordinaire de la
période où il a pris un pays d'abord il
a sauvé la france 140 face aux nazis et
s'il n'y avait pas eu de gaulle on
serait peut-être allemand et l'asie donc
quand même pas génial et deuxième point
et en 58 il à elle une nouvelle fois
sauvé la france de politicards
incompétents qui avait ruiné le pays et
ils la redresser il doit faire le plein
emploi et on vit toujours sur ses
programmes airbus le nucléaire on vit
dessus et qu'est-ce qu'on fait ses
successeurs 0 ils ont ruiné le pays
depuis 30 ans et ils font les malins
toute la journée avec leurs copains des
médias et fabrique des sondages pour
orienter l'opinion et donc moi je dis
aux jeunes secoué vous et allez voter
bazarder cette caste politique nul qu'on
a eu depuis 20 ans bon alors passer à la
question suivante le sens et on l'entend
va passer à la question suivante je
voulais donc il faut toujours le buzzer
toujours le buzzer et on va tomber
c'est un graphique vous le voyez ici
c'est un graphique vers paraître je
propose qu'on le découvre ensemble
c'est un graphique en l'occurrence qui
est extrait de kobe de traqueur que vous
connaissez très sûrement un outil qui
permet de suivre l'évolution de
l'épidémie de corona virus en france ce
qu'on voit là c'est le nombre d'entrées
en soins critiques liées aux corridas
rapporté à la population totale
de chaque groupe donc on a des noms
vacciner donc ça c'est en orange où je
range là on a des partiellement vacciner
totalement vaccinés ou totalement
vacciner avec rappel s'est aussi classé
en fonction de l'âge vous le voyez en
bas nicolas dupont aignan vous êtes très
hostile à la politique sanitaire menée
par le gouvernement et pour autant vous
n'êtes pas anti vaccins c'est parce que
vous ce que vous répétez alors que vous
inspire c'est donner la date de ce corps
je n'arrive pas à voir ça janvier alors
on est sur le on est 16 janvier 2022
effectivement c'est une moyenne moyenne
semaine sur le 16 janvier 2026
moyennement
jeu le taux de cette hospitalisation oui
alors attention les admissions soins
critiques et il ya décès c'est pas la
même chose moi ce que je dis depuis le
début
c'est que la vaccination ne peut être
qu'un élément de la stratégie anti
qu'ovide et qu'elle ne marche que pour
les paires et encore pour les personnes
âgées et fragiles et que la vaccination
des jeunes est une aberration parce que
je pourrais vous montrer à notre
document exactement de la même du
gouvernement de l'adresse qui monte
curieuse de ce document parce que si
vous prenez le document de la drees sur
la mortalité qui est exactement qui
vient du même endroit sûr mois de
janvier très peu de décès chez les
jeunes on sait pas qui a très peu 6-4
aucune différence entre un vacciner à
novak signer chez les moins de 160 ans
les moins de 60 ans que vous soyez
vacciner ou non vacciner le risque qu
vide aujourd'hui et 0 que se faisait
vacciner non vaccinés pour ce que je dis
depuis le départ et les faits me donnent
raison c'est que vouloir vacciner tout
tout le monde est aberrant et notamment
les jeunes parce qu'il ya des effets
indésirables du vaccin et donc des
risques qui sont supérieurs aux
bénéfices
l'élément c'est que je ris je finis
juste ce qui est très grave ce que je
dis c'est que il n'y a que pour les
personnes au dessus de 60 ans et surtout
75 ans que le bénéfice du vaccin est
supérieur au risque et ce que j'ai
toujours dit c'est que y'a les diaquem
en rouge c'est les non vaccinés on s'en
doute chez leméac à un risque oui mais
ça c'est quand j'ai regardé pardonnez
moi mais si vous regardez
sur les décès c'est la propagande c'est
parce que vous mettez soins critiques
après comment vous sortez des soins
critiques et on voit même sur le nombre
de deux sexes et des cif qui ce qui se
rapporte et là en cas de sens critique
des gens qui sont âgés les chiffres
exactement en dessous d'eux en dessous
de 60 ans mais les schistes un qui va ce
sont les chiffres ce sont les chiffres
de l'état qui sait j'ai les chiffres
complètement différente génitales je les
enverrais qui indique en dessous de 60
ans que vous soyez vacciner le non
vaccinés ses équivalents mais en
mortalité
là on bombarde typiquement des personnes
plus âgées ce qu'on voit ici c'est que
la droite le vaccin couche alors sur les
plus jeunes c'est intéressant parce que
c'est l'argument qui a été avancé
pendant longtemps par le gouvernement
c'est le fait que la vaccination certes
n'empêchait pas totalement d'attraper le
colis de alors ses pires adversaires je
vous les aimez mais qu'il permettait de
ralentir la propagation du c'est
complètement faux et en faire c'est
ralentir la propagation coupe ça s'est
avéré complètement faux le 12 juillet le
président de la république a dit si vous
vacciner et vous 24 ans on m'avait dit
tout à l'heure 24 ans vous allez
protéger votre grand mère vous lui
transmettrai pas le virus vous avez 12
fois plus de chances de lui transmettre
si vous n'êtes pas vacciné ça s'est
avéré complet c'est ce qu'il avait dit
le 12 juillet douze fois plus et c'est
tvr est complètement fou d'ailleurs
épreuve c'est qu'il ya eu 20 millions 20
millions de français qui ont attrapé le
coc vide dans une période où il y avait
90% de la population est amenée la
période après les déclarations dormait
mais mais mais ces titres et que tout ça
c'est du pipeau un truc les études
montrent qu' il n'y a pas de protection
totale contre le fait de transmettre
d'attraper le virus on est d'accord
là-dessus il n'y a pas de protection
complète mais par contre ça ralentit
c'est faux c crosser pas fort sinon les
ondes radio a réussi non plus mais c'est
complètement faux et non c'est
complètement faux sinon il y aurait pas
eu des millions de français dans une
population vaccinée à 90% qui aurait
attrapé mais les gens mikron a changé la
donne c'est bien sûr chose ça semble
nettement accéléré la propagation à dieu
en attendant vous pouvez dire tout ce
que vous voulez des français découvrent
aujourd'hui qui a une propagande
incroyable pour vacciner tout le monde
c'est extrêmement grave
parce que c'est sans fin et d'ailleurs
même israël qui était cité en exemple
est le pays où il ya le plus de cas le
plus de morts ils sont arrivés à la
quatrième dose et concrètement il faut
arrêter tout ça il faut faire comme pour
la grippe réservez la vaccination aux
personnes fragiles et âgés et surtout
soigner d'airé cossement déjà en congés
je pense qu'il ya deux sujets qui se
sont mêlés ici à qui mérite qu'on s'y
penche sur la question de la vaccination
des personnes les plus âgées vous êtes
favorable au fait de favoriser la
vaccination pour les personnes les plus
âgées parce que on le voit ça protège
contre les formes graves et donc ça
permet malheureusement pas fait le cas
mais bon c'est pas grave on le voit on
le voit à ce schéma est un schéma de
propagande mais n'ont montré
les chiffres donnés alors comprise a en
tout cas je vais vous dire en israël
donc maintenant il juste et j'aiderai là
dessus dans mais assez important la
vaccination qui me protège contre les
formes graves chez les personnes les
plus âgées et on voit que c'est les
personnes les plus à risque on est
d'accord l'autre sujet au
malheureusement si je peux vous répondre
sauf que malheureusement vous savez ce
qui se passe c'est que nos hôpitaux sont
pleins de triple vacciner âgées qui
meurent plein de plein de tripper écrit
la moitié plus de la moitié puis la
magie son triplé qui sont vaccinés et
qui meurent ils raviraient jaser est ce
que vous savez qu'il y a en décembre
c'était 63% des personnes qui mouraient
dans nos hôpitaux étaient vaccinés 63%
que c'est redescendu à 58 6 ans alors je
faisais les non-vaccinés que je finis un
point quand je dis les 60% sur 63 58
selon les mois c'est vrai qu'il ya plus
de gens 90% adultes qui sont vaccinées
c'est vrai donc ça veut dire qu'il ya un
peu plus de non vaccinés qui meurt que
de vacciner mais malheureusement et
c'est là où il ya un mensonge terrible
de l'état aidé l'industrie
pharmaceutique malheureusement et c'est
dramatique et je préférais que ce ne
soit pas le cas c'est que l'on a fait
croire aux gens que s'ils étaient
vaccinés y avait pas de risque de
transmission que s'ils étaient vaccinés
il aurait pas de forme grave et on a
laissé mourir les gens sans les soigner
et moi je défends une autre politique
qui est oui il peut y avoir une
vaccination qui ralentit pour les
personnages et mes deux grands et plus
jeune non les plus jeunes c'est une
hérésie et de grâce et de grâce
qu'on les soigne en amont quant aux
jeunes je vous dis une chose droit dans
les yeux ne vacciner pas les jeunes
parce qu'il ya des effets indésirables
qu'ils sont plus forts que les bénéfices
du vaccin qui les jeunes ne meurt pas dû
qu'au vide qui pour l'instant ne sont
pas n'ont pas été présente la nsm de
l'état 137000 dont 28% grave et quand tu
% grave de quoi des effets indésirables
terrible va durer sans de 137 millions
en question la semaine dernière 137000
28% et je dis aux jeunes arrêtez de vous
vacciner c'est une hérésie vous allez
faire combien de doses cadeaux cinq
doses fils d'eau alors que vous ne
risquez rien du coc vide et l'industrie
pharmaceutique a fait pression sur le
gouvernement pour vacciner tout le monde
c'est une folie on est alors vacciner
les personnes très âgées mais pas
l'arrêter de vacciner les gens ne
surtout pas les enfants les personnes
âgées mais les vrais nazis contre cette
propagande est un jeu et un jour on me
rendra justice parce que on vous me fout
en l'air votre santé en vous vaccinant à
plusieurs reprises je précise juste un
petit élément à sa sauce alger au sujet
suivant j'en ai assez de la propagande
de l'industrie pharmaceutique relayée
par les médias je me permets juste de
préciser un petit élément sur la
question des jeunes
je n'ai pas du tout que le vaccin
protège et entièrement contre le fait
d'avoir le virus nous transmettre rien
du tout mais mais réduit et réduit les
réserves rien du tout évident mais on
peut en discuter mais typiquement et
linguistique de l'adresse mais arrêtez
avec l'om à statistiques de la grèce est
très ordinaire tous les pays et la suède
ne vaccine tous les jeunes mais depuis
longtemps le danemark parce qu'ils sont
pas corrompues commencement on va
enchaîner avec le sujet sur rim est
juste là tu pries gens respectables la
gande et je voudrais que les jeunes non
mais arrête de cesser bourg et l'âme des
tours et a bien jeté fait là dessus et
après on souhaite aider les questions d
faire préemption des politiques c'est un
terme à puis les faits mais juste
médiathèque justement manipuler
différentes études qui montrent que le
vaccin réduit c'est pas bien empêche pas
complètement méritée il pas vrai si l'on
aime s indique un niveau de protection
contre lorient de 40% et delta mais
aussi une étude de l'an ii 7 ans 9 ans
qui indique que vous saurez ce personnes
arrêtées une chute qui disent exactement
l inverse pour autant on peut dire ces
éléments factuels et être content se
passe à lutter et être contre pas
original parce qu'on voit bien que
effectivement énergie vous avez raison
mais c'est un autre il ya deux choses
mais de grâce qu'on arrête avec ses
études qui nous fait que pour manipuler
la jeunesse et je dis aux jeunes
maintenant à rêver de là nous injecter
un produit dangereux pour vous de grâce
arrêtez vous ne risquez rien du coc vide
faut arrêter cette psychose qui ne le
fait que pour augmenter les profits de
pfizer c'est un sujet qui est important
de répéter pendant pendant longtemps
mais je tiens à dire les choses et les
jeunes vous sont pas cons ils vont
vérifier quoi relancer la roue je vous
laisse je vous laisse est fier parce que
heureusement un programme présidentiel
ce n'est pas que la question d'une arme
et ses nageurs chose et c'est pour ça
que c'était intense il ajouté est en
cause c'est vrai que c'est intéressant
d'en parler et voir quelles mesures est
ce que vous proposez les pressions de
tous les deux tout le pass suppression
de cette scic aux libertés et je serai
le candidat de la liberté on est donc
sur un et mogi c'est une carte vous le
voyez d'art c'était moi j se trouve une
carte on va découvrir ensemble c'est en
l'occurrence c'est pas une carte plus
une carte satellite dresse que vous
reconnaissez cette île c'est l'islande
ne joue pas alors c'est en l'occurrence
née ziegler et au sud de l'océan indien
c'est une île qui vous parle en hp oui
vous parle qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez
installer dessus je mettrai les
islamistes condamnés pour terrorisme
voilà ils iront faire un petit séjour là
bas ça leur fera du bien on est donc
c'est au sud de andy antarctique
pourquoi les passes et je trouve
ahurissant dans ce conte soyons dans un
pays où des gens qui ont massacré
des centaines de personnes à paris le
bataclan etc
puissent être condamnés
et être dans des prisons aux frais de la
princesse c'est à dire du contribuable
et se dire qu'ils pourront recevoir des
visites qui pourront sortir un jour et
c'est donc je pense que de leur faire
passer un petit séjour là-bas à
perpétuité leur fera du bien quelle
différence avec une prison traditionnels
menacés que sinon ils peuvent avoir des
visites et ça pose d'énormes problèmes
de sécurité ça coûte une fortune et ça
sera beaucoup plus simple de les mettre
au travail là bas ils aideront à
entretenir cette île et se fera du bien
pour donner un peu d'éléments de pas
assassiner des français comme ça pour
donner un peu d'éléments là dessus vous
aviez indiqué dans une interview à
peut-être pas vous mais le une personne
de votre équipe de campagne que le en
l'occurrence le cette mesure coûterait
deux fois plus cher par reprise n'est
que dans une prison en métropole quel
serait ce serait resté dans le nouvel
obs que vous avez indiqué ces éléments
là qu'est ce que
je peux plus j'ai déjà l'un d'entre eux
d'essayer à l'ops écoutez ça coûte pas
plus cher mais c'est pas le problème le
problème c'est très simple soit on
rétablit la peine de mort pour ces gens
là soit on les aide durable lp n'ont
donc au je l'aimais loin voilà et je
vais pas accepter ça il ya un moment
faut arrêter quoi faut arrêter avec
cette espèce de naïveté française où des
gens condamnés pour terrorisme sorte au
bout de dix ans de prison enfin jean
marche sur la tête c'est tout mais
qu'est-ce qui est là où c'est
intéressant d'en parler c'est delà du
fait de le laisser au sol et c'est
symbolique oui plus que pratique c'est
symbolique c'est que quand on s'attaque
à la france et quand on lui déclare la
guerre et qu'on tue des innocents
comme au bataclan ou dans les rues de
paris eh bien la france se défend et
n'est pas complètement stupide comme
elle l'est depuis des années face à ces
terroristes je précise d'ailleurs que
les îles de kerguelen s'éteint
un archipel français c'est pour ça que
vous le proposer en l'occurrence a fait
concernant cette question
sécurité ou de terrorisme plus
précisément vous souhaitez aussi déchoir
de la nationalité française les
djihadistes qui ont été condamnés pour
terrorisme françois hollande avait tenté
pendant un moment donné mettre cela en
place après les attentats avant de faire
face et une levée de boucliers dans le
jeu donnait à référendum ce sera très
simple 95 % des français sont pour
l'heure c'est ce qu'a fait l'algérie
d'ailleurs ce qui est quand même
extravagant c'est comme ça ce qu'on
comprenne c'est la déchéance de
nationalité donc la perte de nationalité
française nationaux les personnes qui
ont de nationalisation l'algérie va le
faire avant nous c'est à dire que pour
des binationaux franco algérien un
binational franco algérien l'algérie va
les déchoir de nationalité c'est nous
les français que les recevoir mais on
est complètement malade donc les îles
pas parler de vos mesures sur la
sécurité terrorisme en résumé à sept
îles kerguelen devait être c'est
anecdotique je veux dire que c'est un
des éléments mais l'inde heureusement
éléments c'est pas ça le principal
élément c'est contrôler nos frontières
c'est de lutter beaucoup plus fortement
contre dèche c'est d'avoir une vraie
politique et pas faire semblant voilà
c'est de déchoir de la nationalité ce
qui s'engage c'est de fermer les
mosquées salafistes en france c'est
d'arrêter les financements de l'étranger
c'est d'avoir une vraie politique que
beaucoup plus ferme parce que des
innocents sont morts sur les trottoirs
de paris à cause de la faiblesse des
dirigeants français on va passer à la
question suivante je voulais s'appuyer
toujours commence à connaître la la
mécanique
c'est un hymne au gie particulier qui
est présent sur tous les smartphones
c'est un des billets de banque avec des
ailes mais concrètement on va aborder un
sujet économique bon je vous laisse voir
ce qui va s'afficher à l'écran
c'est en l'occurrence une addition et
pas n'importe laquelle une addition
passer du restaurant c'est plus 100
milliards d'euros qu'elle ce qu'elle ce
compte est ce que vous avez une idée à
quoi ça correspond il ya un lien avec
votre programme d économies que je veux
faire
normalement si c'est bien c'est
exactement ces singes re bien 105
milliards effet c'est le livre que j'ai
publié ou valve pognon exactement ont
fait la pub qui ne coûte que 10 euros et
qui permet de voir tous les grand
gaspillage français
parce que moi je suis pas le père noël
je veux augmenter le pouvoir d'achat je
veux baisser les charges des pme je veux
reconstruire les services publics mais
pour faire simple il faut faire des
économies quelques pas et c'est d'abord
les économies pour que tout le monde
comprenne bien c'est donc c'est un
chiffrage est donc là il est détaillé
ici mais je vais le lire si vous voulez
ou à chaque chacun des éléments il y
écrit concrètement où est ce que vous
comptez aller chercher de l'argent lutte
contre les arrêts des subventions aux
éoliennes 4 milliards d'euros que
voulait faire lutte contre la
concurrence déloyale 19 milliards c'est
un chiffre parents de 105 milliards
d'euros par an comment c'est fait déjà
ce chiffrage pour comprendre un peu là
il a été fait très justement c'est pour
ça que j'ai écrit un livre parce que je
peux pas dire ça comme ça et j'ai repris
des rapports parlementaires j'aimais me
les qr codes pour que chacun puisse
renvoyer vers des rapports
parlementaires qui sont pas faits par
mois qui sont faits par des députés en
marche socialiste républicain donc et
souvent des bi partisan c'est à dire
avec des gens de gauche de droite parce
que je me suis fondé par exemple sur les
20 milliards déjà fraudes à la carte
vitale en général on dit que ça va entre
eux
700 millions et 50 milliards il va j'ai
regardé ont testé duras oui bien sûr
qu'il ait contesté puisque ça fait
trente ans des politiciens incompétents
laisse et la caisse d'assurance maladie
par exemple estime el fen et faux
témoignage devant le sénat c'est ce que
je raconte dans les briquets ménages
c'est-à-dire qu'elle a dit oui ça coûte
des milliards et puis après là on a reçu
un communiqué de presse disant non n'a
pas dit ça la directrice n'a pas dit ça
donc tout le monde sait qui a des
millions de fausses cartes vitales des
mines et l'aveyron 5000 juste pour
comprendre aisément elle estime qu' on a
trente cinquième titre qui en a des
millions qui sont servis je suis pas moi
coûterait il ya eu une inspection des
finances la cour des comptes le sénat
l'assemblée nationale
tout est dans mon livre page 21 je crois
et qui montre qu'il ya des millions de
faux numéros d'immatriculation
c'est à dire c'est du vol c'est du vol
et moi j'en ai assez qu'on baisse les
pensions de retraite qu'on index pas les
pensions de retraites des retraités les
plus modestes parce qu'il ya du vol et
quand je reprends 20 milliards là ça me
permet de faire un treizième mois 13e
mois pour tous les français qui gagnent
jusqu'à 3 fois le smic donc vous leur
verser avec ses économies l'intrigué
d'un treizième mois c'est considérable
considérable donc ce que je veux dire
aux français parce que si je suis
candidat c'est pas pour faire comme les
autres c'est que on dit pas la vérité
aux français moi ce que je leur dis
c'est que si on fait le ménage dans les
dépenses eh ben on peut dépenser mieux
et autrement et j'ai écrit un livre tout
est détaillé tout est précis et ça
oriente tout à fait ma politique parce
qu'on voit très bien quand je veux
lutter contre la grande fraude fiscale à
la tva des grandes entreprises qui
fraude à la tva quand je veux supprimer
8 milliards qui ont été et qui sont
dépensés inutilement sur l'union
européenne quand je vais arrêter qu'on
mette des éoliennes qui polluent tous
les paysages et qui servent à rien parce
qu'elles sont complets du charbon ou du
gaz et je les mets sur l'isolation
thermique va voyait justement sur la
question très précis ça fait 105
milliards par an sont posés ça viendra
avec grèce ivement je lui dis dans mon
livre c'est à dire que c'est au bout des
cinq ans ça se fait pas comme ça c'est
très dur on dira alors certains juste
chiffres surévalués mai mais
concrètement sur ses 105 milliards
d'euros vous ai parlé de hausse de
pouvoir d'achat avec 20 milliards que
vous souhaitez alloué à cette hausse de
pouvoir d'achat vous avez parlé pouvoir
d'achat pour les salariés devant les
salariés les retraités en plus j'allais
vous demandez sûrement les autres
éléments qui sont prévus dans ce que tu
peux prévoir sur les 105 milliards c'est
très simple un tiers pour le pouvoir
d'achat 35 milliards c'est à dire les
salariés à 13e mois sans augmenter les
charges des entreprises les retraités on
indexe les pensions de retraite pascal
un retraité aujourd'hui avec 3 %
d'inflation quand vous avez une retraite
de 1100 euros au bout de 3 ans et 10 %
en moins vous aurez pu vivre et c'est le
drame aujourd'hui notre pays et puis ça
ce sera là les principales mesures se
fait 35 milliards 35 milliards sur la
baisse des l'impôt sur les sociétés pour
les entreprises qui investissent en
france ce qui donne aux actionnaires
rien ceux qui investissent à l'étranger
taxer ceux qui investissent en france un
bonus fiscal donc c'est réorienter
l'activité en france et puis le
troisième pilier 30,39 moins de 30
milliards un peu plus 30 milliards c'est
la reconstruction de l'hôpital de
l'école de l'université parce que il
faut offrir de nouveaux équipements
universitaire hospitalier
et scolaire fesci vous avez eu vos
premières mesures la question de la
santé de l'hôpital près de 10 milliards
d'euros que vous souhaitez investir et
qu'il faut faire des économies parce que
moi je vois tous les autres candidats
mais concurrents c'est incroyable alors
ils promettent des milliards comme moi
si je puis dire mais ils disent pas
qu'ils croyaient trouver donc en fait
ils feront rien du tout doux l'addition
condition qu'on a su le seul à l'avoir
fait un j'assiste essai sur internet
de voir tout ça
ce sera là la dernière question
d'ailleurs et on tombe sur abbas est
très bien et mogi au tricolore un
drapeau tricolore alors des recettes et
mogi en fait vous allez devoir reprendre
une formule que vous connaissez sans
aucun doute une formule de françois
hollande qui a été prononcée en 2012
face à nicolas sarkozy le fameux mois
président comment ça va se passer
il ya une série de phrases qui vont
s'afficher à l'écran je vous laisse du
coup les lire et complétez ensuite en
une phrase chacune de ses phrases qui
vont s'afficher liaison là aussi de
mieux comprendre votre vision de la
france on va commencer avec le premier
mois présidence volet solidaire et le
compléter en une phrase moi président ma
première mesure sera l'augmentation la
récompense du travail par l'augmentation
des salaires
mois président mon ennemi
sera
en référence à françois hollande que
vous éditez même la violence mais j'ai
pas recommencer parce que il a
lamentablement échoué et mais moi mon
ennemi sera seront les adversaires de la
france
la première visite officielle alors je
vous suis pas moi président ma première
visite officielle sera au maghreb dans
les trois capitales du maghreb pourquoi
du maroc de l'algérie et la tunisie
parce que si ces pays ne tiennent pas et
ne se développe pas nous aurons le vrai
problème migratoire français et je veux
que ces pays se développe lutte contre
l'islamisme et soient ainsi des pays
équilibrée que nous ayons des belles
relations entre nous pour éviter une
immigration massive en enchaîne pour les
jeunes je alors moi président pour les
jeunes je créerai le travail universelle
c'est quoi c'est qu'en échange d'un
travail d'intérêt général pour les
collectivités et les hôpitaux
y ait un salaire
habitants je les fais dans ma vie le
contrat sera universel qu'est ce que je
suis content le revenu universel je suis
contre le fait qu'on soit 500 euros sans
rien faire en revanche il faut donner
une chance aux jeunes on a vu que tous
leurs petits boulots ou disparus et la
crise du coc vide je les fais dans ma
ville où il ya hier dans l'eau quand
j'étais maire il permis de conduire
gratuit en échange de 15 jours de
travail enfin pas gratuit totalement moi
de moi tu c'est-à-dire moitié gratuits
moitié n'excède pas un travail d'intérêt
général tout le monde s'est moqué de moi
quand j'ai lancé ça ça a très bien
marché il ya aujourd'hui lancar à des
jeunes qui peuvent à 6 payer le permis
de conduire et ce thème avant le porter
à l'échelle de la france voilà ce sera
le dernier mois précédent la france
indépendante et les français libres
c'est à dire que il faut arrêter avec
les mesures de contrôle social malsaine
qui empêche la liberté de ceux des
français merci beaucoup nicolas dupont
aignan merci accepté cet air cet échange
est intéressant d'avoir votre point de
vue de comprendre votre programme votre
vision de la france sachant que ça
reviendra et je dis surtout pour ceux
qui nous regardent mais ça viendra en
complément d'une vidéo de décryptage de
votre programme houba comme pour tous
les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle ça ne semble important
car ce travail sera bien pour la
regardera avec attention vous aurez
l'occasion de le voir dans l'est dans
les prochains jours merci et encore
merci à vous alors accepté l'invitation
nicolas dupont aignan et ce sera tout du
coup pour cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle
vous aura plu chez mais c'est le cas
évidemment n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
sur youtube pour ne pas louper les
entretiens les interviews suivante et
aussi du coup les décryptages de tous
les programmes à des candidats à
l'élection présidentielle
les liens pour en savoir plus sur tout
ça sont directement en descriptions
merci encore merci à dupont aignan merci
beaucoup